كشفت كينيا الستاره عن بنود الاتفاقيه
السريه التي حاولت الصين اخفائها لسنوات
كينيا كسرت حاجز الصمت عن شروط بكين
القاسيه حول مشروع خط السكه الحديديه
الموقعه عام 2014
ثلاث وثائق تبين كيف تورطت نيروبي بدفع
نحو خمسه مليارات دولار لشركات صينيه
استحودت على عقود البناء والتصميم
القطار الذي كان من المفترض ان يربط شرق
البلاد بغربها لم يكتمل بسبب امتناع الصين
عن تمويل القسم الاخير منه هذا التوقف
يحرم الكنيين من حصد جدوى اكبر مشاريع
البنيه التحتيه ويزيد اعباءها الاقتصاديه
وديونها لكن اكتمال المشروع يبدو سيئا
بقدر توقفه في الصين تتحكم بصرف عائداته
وتشترط حلا النزاعات حوله في محاكمها
المحليه
اما في حال التخلف عن سداد قرض اخر
فيجبروا العقد سداد قرض الصين اولا ويحق
لبكين حينها التوقف عن التمويل
ورغم ان بنود العقد منعت الافصاح عن اي
تفاصيل لطرف ثالث لكن خبراء وصفوا الخطوه
بانها محاوله للضغط على بكين لاعاده
التفاوض قد تكون كينيا قدمت تنازلات اكبر
بكثير بحيث لم تستطع الافصاح عنها بعد
للحصول على القرض الصينيه لكنها بلا شك لم
تكن الدوله الافريقيه الاولى ولا الوحيده
ديون الدول الافريقيه للصيد بلغت 200
مليار دولار عام 2019
ومصانعها وصلت لاكثر من 10,000 تنتج اثنا
عشر بالمئه من انتاج القاره الافريقيه